do you guys think that men should date  girls that have dated bad boys in the  past because while this is her tune now  i would guess in 10 years it might be a  very different tune oh it would  definitely be a different tune i think  and so then go around everyone so you  can yeah i think it will definitely be a  different tune for her because the wall  always hits women  and the wall when the wall hits that's  when it's like this they have an  epiphany and it's like sudden  realizations and stuff like that and  then everything that people was telling  them in their past that they shouldn't  be doing or they should be going for  this kind of man is that  all of those things come in at once